The Villages that I went to they have
plenty of food
but you take a shower in a bucket some
say that's even healthier for you I
don't know I don't know if people say
that I just made it
[Music]
all right so there's this guy in San
Francisco his name is Michael
he uh has his neighbor that tells him
about this charity that he's uh working
with and it's a charity for Bangladeshi
kids that are very poor and they need
food and clothing sounds fake
it's a very real charity but so I don't
believe them I just saw an article that
the Bangladesh is going to be the number
one richest South East Asian country
I don't think there's a lower class
still
no it's like a wakanda
looking wakanda
so uh he decides to donate 150 bucks to
the charity and then he types it in and
then he receives a thank you email for
his donation of fifteen thousand forty
one dollars oh no [__] and he's like
what what the hell and he realizes that
when he was typing in his credit card
info that his cursor was still on the
dollar amount so that's why it added
like a 41 on it so he basically emails
GoFundMe and he tells him the situation
he's like hey I did not mean to send
this much money but I'm not that good
again yeah right has that conversation
with him GoFundMe says okay that's fine
it happens all the time uh it'll just
take like a week though for you to get
your money back they're gonna refund him
the whole amount
during that week longest week of his
[__] life longest week of his life he
starts receiving hundreds of thank you
notes and videos from Bangladeshi kids
including videos of them holding signs
with his name saying thank you Michael
all these like his thing shows up on the
top of the GoFundMe chart as a guy that
that uh donated 15 000. so it's like
it's very public so they're probably
like oh my God we could feed the whole
village for five years they're so
excited like we're not gonna be hungry
anymore and he's just receiving our boys
just sweating huh sweating and he's get
every day do you think that he feels
like he's like stealing a little bit of
their Joy because he knows that he's in
the middle of a refund process yeah he's
watching these videos and he's like oh I
can't enjoy it though but the whole time
he's probably tell him stuff he's like
dude it's fine it's gonna be fine it's
gonna be it's gonna be the wakanda of of
the area it's the wakanda the area I
heard they already have enough money
yeah it's gonna be fine like they're
gonna be fine this article me they are
the fastest rising [__] GDP in
southeast and you know what happens when
the when the the GDP goes up right the
poorer people get lifted up
like that poverty gets abolished yeah
the Gap keeps getting big it's like
during covet right huh 200 billion
dollars right went all the way down it
went all the way down so it almost was
like it came out of the ground that's
right yeah because it went it would
trickle up economic trickled up yeah so
here's a picture of like that's the
GoFundMe those are the kids holding
signs of his name
so he's getting the ton of these all the
time what's he gonna do something [__]
it just keep it I 15 Jesus that's
something so he does not keep the
donation in he gets his refund and then
he decides to change his uh donation to
1500. and he tells the organizer like
hey this is what happened he should have
told him already I mean he waits for the
refund no maybe he did though I don't
know but I'm such a coward I would have
changed my [__] name that's why I was
thinking he was gonna say and then so he
changed his name's address
new identity he moved on he's talking to
the organizer and he's like yeah it's
it's my donation was meant to be much
lower was an accident the organization
is super cool about it and they're like
oh no trust us like 1500 still goes a
really long way so thank you so much
they're really cool about it like
there's no shame they don't like put him
out they don't like expose him or
nothing they're just super cool so uh
this guy Michael ends up like telling
his story about what he did on Reddit
and then the Reddit blows up and they
all start donating and the charity
made's like 120k wow that's cool wow I
thought they were gonna go bad on him or
something me too
not even the nature of Reddit [__]
penis is going in his mouth
I know what that feels like that's the
bad ending yeah yeah so the charity
ended up making even more money and then
Michael comes back and goes can I get
like at least a thousand back scratch
I started it yeah yeah exactly can I be
marketing director can I get paid for it
for 1500 a month I was expecting it to
be a really sad ending so I'm glad it
was happy yeah this is a crazy story
actually so is that more money than they
ever need no one needs ever done
anything he's out they're trying to say
I think so I think they halted old
donations
what was it for they hungry oh there's
no yeah they're hungry because maybe
they should just now build farms
150 Grand 150 Grand how much come on
dude you could live for years exactly
yeah so okay just spaghetti and marinara
yeah all you need is enough food to last
you until the the harvest season
and then when you start growing okay
then you start making your own food
[Laughter]
homies know I don't know if you could
grow beans but have you ever thought
about beans
or like because rice is actually very
hard to grow man yeah it's not easy and
and Bangladesh is a small country not a
lot of rice space what's something that
they could grow beans okay what else a
lot of protein yeah peas peas very small
have you seen a pea yeah does it take
much space Have you seen the pee yeah do
you need a lot of it
that's funny
do you know um what a high poverty rate
is or a low power rate do you have an
idea of like the scale no so the poverty
rate now in Bangladesh is 18.7 percent
oh wow
yeah then that's a good clap go ahead
because it's low no hold on I'll tell
you yeah you want to Applause clap first
go ahead I thought it was like low
number but it doesn't sound that low
when you think about it 18 of the
population that sounds pretty low
actually
poverty though poverty and you have you
have to Define poverty because per
country it's different lower than 50.
poverty in Bangladesh is probably
different than poverty in the U.S yeah
poverty out there is like
you live in the tent
because I feel like some places like 50
Maybe
well um I think that it says the poverty
rate in America last recorded was like
11 yeah but American poverty you still
got a stove and a refrigerator and a
bathroom and an Xbox they're living bro
they get to break all the laws yeah you
live better than the Pharaohs you live
better than the Kings that's true yeah
yeah but you got AC you got [__] AC
you've got the internet on your [__]
phone it is it is not anything you
wanted from REI
just walk in taking walk out when I was
doing Trolling Videos I had a homeless
guy who had a phone and he was like oh
yeah I've seen you before on YouTube and
I'm like how do you watching me on
YouTube and he's like
um
so that that percentage is actually
lower than it was the year before so
it's good that's what's popping dude
that's cool it's cool
but like what point five percent
yeah something like that it's not it but
it is you you are right they are like uh
they the country as a whole is doing
better you know one of the things that
like I also hear like not only I
experienced but I hear from so many
people too that travel to like like
southeast Asia or whatever right man you
meet some of the happiest people like
yeah they'll be like laughing and [__]
they only got like three teeth living in
a shack and every day it's like I'm like
dang dude you literally look stress-free
but in my head I'm thinking oh poor you
you know like yeah like you live in a
shack and this and that but then like
their Vibes just like how much they play
and like just when you're eating and and
you just see them around the streets and
stuff I'm like I think you live better
than me yeah why don't it that's why I
donations you're chilling dude that's
the facade of like yeah oh I have a
house they should be donating to us I
wish they did I need the help that'd be
nice dude that'd be sick then I get a
new pair of shoes baby because like we
have depression over here but the irony
is never seen how much sheet metal costs
here we're in our cars going to work
right and then we go to like office we
have a nice house and [__] and it's like
a hamster wheel every day and then for
them like they might not have the same
stuff but they're not complaining
they're not like it's just a different
world I still think I would want
something in between
are you sure yeah you don't know that
dude do they even dollar cost average
over there I think yeah what's their DC
I know it is funny that in the first
world like we have created a lot more
problems to solve so it is but in the
third world they don't have anxiety
they have to hunt for food every single
day
um do you think they have social anxiety
they don't know if they're gonna eat
tonight
but they probably don't have anxiety
like we do yeah anxiety is tough dude
right sometimes I can't go to sleep and
I gotta watch YouTube all night
to fall asleep or HBO Max
or Hulu
The Villages that I went to they have
plenty of food
but you take a shower in a bucket so
some say that's even healthier for you
I don't know I don't know if then people
say that
no they'll just be like chicken and pigs
everywhere and then like it'll be dinner
time and we're like what are we having
big and I'm like they just feel I just
got one of the pigs there baby that's
organic baby that's [__] free range
it was bomb dude it was so good my
family in the Philippines lives and
they're
not super happy all the time well you
know what one of the things because
they're Filipinos
but isn't that a product of you knowing
them and not just walking by them on a
street like Joe did exactly so he could
judge an entire situation and just go
there much happier but also but you know
a little bit more yes that's interesting
but also though too like they don't have
to worry about getting their food from
factory farms and how miserable those
animals are you know like oh yeah we
have the luxury of that we're eating
death on like a regular basis and it's
just like not good for us at all no
because those animals had had anxiety
when they were getting killed and then
we put that in our box and that's all we
get you would never think double anxiety
you would never think that the chicken
that you personally raised in your own
yard for
months and we have less guilt when you
kill it exactly unlike ours when we eat
these giant chickens that are all big
and like stuffed juicy yeah and then and
they're living in these tiny little
coops and we hate ourselves and each
other for eating these guys I don't I
mean we're pieces of [__] for that yeah
but it does taste good to make me happy
when it's fried but those are the
problems that they don't have to worry
about that we have to worry about well
you're talking to the country that made
jelly be my friend
[Music]